how did you get your first script in the
hands of john carpenter
well it was the first thing i i wrote
i'd been working as a producer on indie
films and
and music videos and commercials and was
like i'm gonna
take the leap into screenwriting so i
saved enough money for one year
to just work on screenwriting and um had
this idea to do like a very pulp fiction
type horror film
you know kind of non-linear and i had a
friend who was a screenwriter
sean keller who became my writing
partner and
we'd never worked together we just
decided to write it and just
after three months just working on the
script with like
you know no expectations we ended up
getting a manager from it because it was
so unusual and odd and different than
what was out there
and then from there you know i get a
call a few weeks later said john
carpenter read it loves it
so i grew up watching his movies and by
the way he's the greatest guy on the
face the earth he's the coolest dude you
could ever meet
so he read the script liked it and was
very interested in directing it and his
process
was to sit there with the script and
read it aloud to us page by page
and everything that he didn't like or
thought wasn't good he'd just go come on
you could do better than that which was
which was a learning experience in
itself
and it showed it taught me a lot about
what directors are looking for
and what they want and he was a great
teacher and the film never got made
but it was a really good experience and
then from that
we actually did an uncredited rewrite on
his last film uh the award
so it worked out great because we got
paid to to rewrite the film
so we've worked with carpenter twice and
he's a really good dude
and so this was the second script that
you and your writing partner had that
was actually the first one oh
okay sorry but but how did you how did
this manager and how did all this
even get in the hands of john carpenter
well i had spent
time like the first 10 years of work in
the film industry i worked
for production companies and produced
some indie films and things so i kind of
knew how the business worked a little
bit i had an unfair advantage
to most people just stepping in but i
spent 10 years working in the world and
making some connections and also
understanding how you know scripts work
so i really had worked on a few things
where it's like i could probably write
as well as that
you know or even you know saw what other
people were making and some other
screenplays i was like i think i could
do that
so that's kind of where it came out of
and just
you know we also knew that we had to
write something that was really unusual
out of the box we didn't write a script
to be made we wrote a script to get
noticed
and that's where i think really it
worked it was like okay this gets made
that's great but people will not forget
the script and it did what it was
supposed to do
because it got us you know it got us a
manager and then later got us an agent
from another script and just kept the
ball rolling and people still ask me
about that script and we've optioned it
i don't know maybe six or seven times
the last 15 years still hasn't been made
but
it's it's done well and when you sat
down
with uh john carpenter where was this
like an office building yeah he has like
i'm not going to say where's office
but he has yeah he has an old craftsman
i think maybe he lived there like
20 30 years ago that he still owns it's
been converted into office
so it's cool you go in there and all his
posters are up all his scripts are there
you know he just sits in the back office
and and just you know
most of time when we would talk about
the script we'd also talk about
basketball
and music and all these other things and
he gave me a lot of advice about the
film business
you know he would say you know people
are going to rip you off they're going
to do this they're going to do that
don't start writing until you get paid
you know do this and that and one of the
best stories i have about him
is when we were doing a uh rewrite on
the ward for him there was a big
conference call with all these producers
and everybody kept telling us what to do
and he stopped everyone
and he just said hey let let them go do
what they do
and it was the coolest thing because we
knew all we had to do was just talk to
carpenter you know it's like
deal with everybody else and pretty much
the script the rewrite we did was the
movie that
that you saw so yeah
and when he started going through the
script and saying you can do better than
that
did he did he show you what better was
within the script
no he no he's he let you he kind of
treated you as
a professional it's like this can be
better which
means you need to go figure out how to
make it better you know and
just some lines he'd be like you know a
hero would never say that the lead of
the movie wouldn't say that
you know so it was a good good you know
education and understanding that like
they're not gonna do the work for me and
things i didn't do correctly in a script
it's like you know and and that's not
necessarily their job it's like this
isn't working so you need to give me
option a
b and c so that was a really good lesson
you know from somebody who knows
films backwards and forwards and so when
you and sean
left there with your whether you put
paper clips or
post-it notes or whatever how are you
racking your brain to go why didn't he
like this what you know
like no it was just like i can't believe
we're hanging out john carpenter more
more than anything but but he was so
he's he's like like
he's probably one of the best people
i've ever met not just in the film
business but just a great
great person and super cool and just you
know gives great advice and it was just
he didn't do it because he was you know
from a place of like come on it was more
like you can do better and he would say
you can do better
just you know was really pushing and and
really dug the script
and you know to have somebody who you
watch these movies growing up say that
it's like
you better listen you know so it was
part it was it's part of educating
yourself
i still i've been doing this 15 years
professionally as a screenwriter i'm
trying to educate myself
all the time to get better every day so
good lesson and jim were you paid for
the script
no that one was just work to try to get
it to the finish line
that happens sometimes sometimes things
are options sometimes they're not if
you're you have a good attachment like a
director like him
you know you sometimes work on trying to
get to the next level to go out to get
the financing
so not every job you know every every
project you work on is
you know you're not always getting paid
sometimes you have to you have to make
that decision do you want to do the work
to try to get to the next level or do
you want to try to get
paid you know sometimes there's no one's
going to pay you
so it's like there's it's either the
market doesn't want it right now or will
want it with attachments or you know
it's a tricky thing
most people in the film business you
won't make money unless multiple people
want to
buy the project if just one person wants
to make it they're like sure we'll give
you an option we'll do this um
we may have optioned that script i don't
really remember but it wasn't
you know it was never purchased so and a
lot of times you just get an option you
don't get paid for a script you read
these stories of people you know selling
a script here or there that happens
but if you're more in the indie world 10
million and under you option a script
maybe they'll give you five grand maybe
they'll give you 10 grand maybe they'll
give you
a hundred dollars and when the movie
gets made
the first day of shootings when they
actually pay for the script
so if you want to be a team player and
get the movie mate you have to work a
lot for free
and so going there you and sean both
knew we're not going to be paid but we
see the opportunity
exactly down the line exactly it was
like having a master class it's like you
know it's
yeah where the guy's sitting there you
can ask me if you want so
that's great what's the story behind
your first screenplay sale
so first screenplay sale was the script
we wrote after
the john carpenter project which is
called elli gothic this was called
damned and this script
was got out and it was picked up by a
pretty big producer
and they arranged the financing for the
film and they actually paid for the
script
and what happened was a few days before
shooting it was fully cast
um i think they were shooting on like a
monday and this was friday the cast was
getting on plane flights to fly out to
missouri and they get these frantic
calls like don't get on the plane
because the money fell out three days
before principal photography and
that happens sometimes in films until
you're actually i even have the theory
that on an indie film until you're
actually finished shooting
you don't that's when you don't really
have to worry about the money so much
you have to worry about
posts but i've worked on films where
sometimes they don't have all the money
they say they
they do so it's a problem that happens
but
you know it was it was sad we got paid
at least
you know we got the rights to script
back they were great to give us that
back because the movie didn't get made
and we optioned it several more times
but it was you know it was very
disappointing because that was the first
thing i thought was going to get made
and it didn't it got very close and it
just fell apart
but you know you live and you learn and
then you move on to the next project
keep going
so that didn't deter you no not at all
no it's like it was it actually made me
think even more okay we got to work even
harder on the next project and
and get something made cause it came so
close and finally we're making some
money as screenwriters and and we were
like let's do it it's not like you know
no actually it actually emboldened me to
even go harder and things
and so in a case like that who calls the
the actors the location is that's the
producer that's yeah making all these
horrible calls
that's probably got to be very difficult
yeah and so
there was no chance of maybe in a month
it was basically this is done
they they talked about it but usually in
these kind of projects if that happens
it's it's kind of hard to regroup you
spend so many months
putting the whole team together doing
everything getting the actors in line
you know getting their schedules
making deals and then for it all to go
sideways and not know when you're going
to pick it back up
it's very difficult it does happen don't
get me wrong but it's it becomes like
okay you know there's a little bit of a
jinx on a project at that point so
you just kind of have to move on and and
just try to make the next one
and sorry this was your first screenplay
that you wrote or you second oh second
okay with sean yeah okay and
with the first one um did you
expect anything from that that was the
john carpenter one you know the
expectations were just to get noticed
really because it was it was really kind
of crazy and
and that's another thing i talk to
people a lot about it's like you know
what are your expectations with the
script is it
you know if you write something to sell
it or to get it made or to get noticed
and a lot of i think young screenwriters
don't try to write something to get
noticed
you know because if you want to do this
for a living it's something that you've
got to like you're not just going to
write one script you're going to be
writing every day all the time
and have tons of scripts do you think
the chain of events would have happened
today
because things have changed so rapidly
in so many ways do you think
that same story could be duplicated
again
either one whether you get a script that
you know you won't be paid for but into
the hands of some
master class person basically a master
definitely happens all the time
a lot of people who become big writers
um
they they write a script that turns into
a sample and even i've had that several
times my career where there's like a
sample of like a horror film that
everybody was into and then a thriller
that everybody was into
and then i recently wrote a really big
action film that that's
getting a lot of traction right now but
it's also just in the last few weeks
got me up for some big writing gigs
because
you know if you're trying to get a job
for a 80 million dollar action film you
can't show them a one million dollar
horror film
you have to have that sample that gets
people's attention
and you know professional high-level
producers read
they know by your sample if you can do
the other job
so you know you have to have samples
that fit that that kind of what you
the type of work you're looking for so
it was a great sample
so
you